our series changing the game highlights
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
generations for Black History Month we
are focusing on black entrepreneurs and
creators and this morning we are
introducing you to Summer Lucille she is
the founder of the fashion brand for
Kirby women called juicy body goddess
over the past 10 years Lucille has
created a space for plus-sized women
from work attire to date night looks in
her North Carolina store she encourages
women and girls to embrace their Curves
in post inspiring videos on her Tick
Tock page with more than a million
followers check it out
welcome to juicy body God is who you got
to be too some to do some
um she looks so beautiful do a twirl for
me oh my goodness you look absolutely
stunning you look absolutely beautiful
you look like a goddess for real yeah I
love that on you baby how it make you
feel confident that's all I asked for
your shape is So Divine it is beautiful
and then you're beautiful you just got a
real nice happy you make me happy your
smile makes me happy
Tick Tock recently named summer Lucille
to its first ever Visionary voices list
that recognizes 15 black creators good
morning how you doing good morning I'm
doing amazing you got to be doing
something to do something you got to be
too something to do something that's
true
okay summer don't hurt them
I try not to you're doing it though you
look good doing it thank you so what was
the motivation behind creating a space
for plus-sized women being plus-sized
All My Life coming from a plus size
family uh I wanted to be a voice for the
plus size body
um be an advocate and also provide
fashion forward clothing for plus size
we make up 72 percent women over the
size 12 in America make up 72 percent of
our population and we're not heard we're
not in the stores so I wanted to create
a space where we're safe we're welcomed
and we feel good about what celebrated
and celebrate it and I wanted to create
that it was nowhere I couldn't go
anywhere and sometimes you got to kick
the door open and create it yourself you
said that you were um
you were tired at one point you were the
sad fat depressed girl your words not
mine yes yes ma'am and you said for you
this is so much bigger than fashion this
is so I do not want anybody to
experience what I would experienced
through my lifetime just being
plus-sized feeling like I was wrong
because of my size going into different
stores never been able to find anything
your mom was helpful too what did your
mom say to you
um
ever since she's the reason why I'm I'm
confident she was my mother was over 600
pounds at one point went through the
struggles of trying to lose weight I
myself would seen her go through that I
was chubby myself and she always told me
you're not going to be the skinniest
you're not going to be the prettiest the
richest the smallest but you are the
best you are summer Lucille and you
always hold your head high don't let
nobody treat you any kind of way don't
let nobody talk to you any kind of way
and that's what I hear in my head every
day with Summer here's the other we got
time for the riches by the way
here's the other side summer because
we're always raised that it's better for
your health I'm not I don't want to be
inappropriate or insensitive here but do
you think that have you tried to lose
weight did you ever have a desire to
lose weight because people say how can
you be healthy absolutely I have tried I
have tried every diet like Beyonce died
the Kanye pepper diet the Cabbage diet
watermelon diet the boiled egg diet
I still can't eat boiled eggs to this
day because of that diet I've lost 100
pounds the most I've ever lost was like
125. I I know how to lose weight it's
just
The Stereotype between health and people
trying to correlate health and obesity
that's to me is a way to discriminate
against bigger and fat people you can be
fat and healthy the BMI is based on a
male man Caucasian man I am the opposite
so that's not even scientifically proven
or backed by science the BMI scale so
people want to use that as a crutch for
us but I'm I'm screaming you can be fat
and healthy I am fat and healthy and
happy and happy I'm the fattest I've
ever been and I'm the happiest I've ever
been because I get to eat
okay
good you hear me
as you can see
and on the subjects are the riches
because Nate's not wrong right
are already coming people are traveling
from as far as Australia Australia yes
like seeing people walk in from all over
the world it's humbling it just I and I
know my customers probably think I'm
weird because I I tear up when people
say they drove from California or
full-on for New York Australia I just I
it's a humbling experience and it is
reinforcement I am living my purpose
yeah this is what I'm meant to do this
is my path and when they tell me I just
I just get I just my mind is blown every
time yeah before you go I know you spend
your time celebrating other women as you
post your videos I'll say this to you
and we'll say this you are beautiful and
we celebrate you this week I love your
confidence and your enthusiasm thank you
and I want those shoes
this is my team okay we're working out
in the commercial break that was a darn
good experience
thank you very much great to meet you
we'll be right back